president kelly over the weekend so that
he was going to build bitcoin city how
do you fund all of this well there's
going to be zero percent income tax
there's gonna be zero percent capital
gains tax there's gonna be zero percent
property tax zero percent payroll tax
and zero percent municipal taxes how the
hell can you fund a city a brand new
city without having any level of
taxation there's not zero taxes there is
going to be a 10 sales tax which will
drive some revenue for the city but on
top of that they also are going to fund
a lot of this using something called a
bitcoin backed bond now most cities as
you know issue bonds that's how they
raise debt they go ahead and they pay
interest on that debt and they use those
funds to do things within the city to
further push it forward from progress
and evolution standpoint but this
bitcoin-backed bond is very interesting
because what they are going to do is
they are going to issue a one billion
dollar municipal bond a bitcoin back
municipal bond that one billion dollar
bond will take 500 million of the
proceeds of the bond they will go ahead
and they will buy bitcoin with 500
million dollars to buy bitcoin out of
the bond the other 500 million dollars
is going to go towards infrastructure
bitcoin mining in the area etc it's
going to go towards actual things for
the city itself and so the idea is that
the bond will pay 6.5 yield out to
investors which is very attractive from
a municipal bond standpoint and over a
couple of years they will liquidate the
bitcoin that they purchased from the
bond revenue and they will go ahead and
they will pay back investors the yield
that they owe but there's also a special
dividend that special dividend of the
bond will be increased profits from the
bitcoin liquidations will ultimately end
up being returned to investors as well
and so having a bitcoin backed bond is
really interesting but it's even more
interesting when you look at a bitcoin
backed bond used to help facilitate the
building of bitcoin city in a country
where bitcoin is legal tender and so
when i start to look at this the two
things that immediately jumped to mind
for me first microstrategy was the
canary in the coal mine it broke the
seal for public companies it basically
said we are going to make it a thing
where public companies can buy bitcoin
and put it on their balance sheet then a
bunch of other companies started to do
it as well and we saw everyone from
square to tesla to a bunch of uh bitcoin
or crypto native companies also putting
bitcoin and other crypto assets on their
balance sheet so micro strategy broke
the seal a bunch of people followed el
salvador is doing the exact same thing
for nation state el salvador not only
made it legal tender not only did they
create the chivo wallet the bitcoin atms
and also the bitcoin mining facility but
now they are literally going to build a
bitcoin city with bitcoin-backed bonds
and so do not be surprised if there's a
bunch of fast followers that just like
microstrategy was the pioneer in public
markets el salvador will be the pioneer
in the nation-state race and if they
continue to do this and they continue to
plug their country into the bitcoin
network they're simply hiring millions
and millions and millions of people
around the world to all work in unison
to help push el salvador to the front of
the geopolitical race it's pretty damn
cool to see so joe and john when you
guys saw this what did you think in
terms of uh buchelli saying that he was
going to build bitcoin city joe maybe
you first i thought it was interesting
pretty wild actually i didn't see that
coming at all but when you think about
the taxes right i think they're going to
have value-added tax the bad tax but
they're not gonna have any income tax
any property tax any capital gains tax
uh no municipal taxes uh et cetera and
then and then bitcoin is gonna obviously
be legal tender so i think it's
interesting it'll be uh it'll be
interesting to also see who's gonna move
there right like do they convince
current citizens of el salvador to move
there do they convince people outside of
el salvador to move there is there
there's some kind of economic benefit uh
from people coming into el salvador and
moving in there full-time i think
that'll be interesting but it's cool
right they're literally going to use
energy from a volcano and i think the
coolest thing about all this is this is
all being crowdsourced on twitter which
i think is wild to think about because a
lot of these ideas i think president
buchelli said were tweeted at him or
ideas that people had given him in the
past on twitter so it's interesting to
see a country just adopting this stuff
so quickly and rapidly but also doing it
through kind of a public approach
kelly's crazy i love it it will be
interesting to see like who actually
goes and lives in the city because of
this right um obviously taxes are
something a lot of people think about
the us has insanely high tax rate uncle
sam always gets his money per se but um
there's other countries that have really
low taxes a 5.6
return is great um right now people are
obviously looking for those 10xs over a
long period of time i don't really know
how much mayor like who's really going
to move there i'm not going to move
there uh just based off what they're
doing but i think some people will and i
think it just even draws more attention
to el salvador within the bitcoin
community and as we've talked about
bitcoin enthusiasts are they're
enthusiastic right they have a lot of
energy and they kind of uh rally around
stuff like this so i think it will get a
lot of traction very quickly well he
also said that they're gonna start the
city in 2022 like that's coming up in
the first half of 2022 so they're
obviously going to start making some
progress on this pretty soon uh so we
should have answered this sooner rather
than later i don't think that majority
of people are going to go move there but
what i do think is going to happen is
that there are a ton of people who
already have visited el salvador who
previously went so this is a boom for
tourism this is a boom for business uh
on top of that i do think that some
people will move there i don't know what
the number is i don't know from
percentage basis how really to even
measure it but if you go ahead and you
look not only is it a beautiful country
not only are there things like surfing
and you know things that people enjoy uh
but also it's similar to the uh kind of
reckoning or the uh uh excitement around
miami right why do people in the united
states love miami uh well they feel like
the local government is cheering for
them rather than trying to punish them
they feel like the tax situation is uh
advantageous for them they feel like
there's a ton of energy around we want
you to be successful here tell us what
we can do to help you and we're going to
help push you forward and then we're
basically going to give you the resource
you need to get the hell out of your way
and so ultimately i think that what we
are watching is from a geopolitical
standpoint either at the nation state
level or if you go all the way down to
states and cities is that there's
competition and ultimately people are
choosing to move and vote with either
their feet or their wallets and so just
as people have gotten excited about
miami and all started to move here and
really kind of made this big push from a
technology standpoint i do believe that
el salvador they're going to continue to
execute they're going to continue to do
this and they will also be the
beneficiary of these decisions because
more and more people will move there
more and more people will visit and
naturally what you'll get is you'll get
some kind of cohesion or or uh kind of a
concentration of people there and all
you need is that flywheel to start once
the flywheel starts then it's game on
and then it's really really hard to
unlock that network effect right if i
want to go somewhere in south or central
america well i might as well go to el
salvador because i know there's a bunch
of bitcoiners there right or i know that
they're friendly to bitcoin it serves as
a marketing campaign for the country
rather than having to go and buy a bunch
of ads on television or do something
else you can simply go and say look i
want to be a part of this
and i want to go visit